welcome to the show everybody I trust
you're all excited for the democratic
debate tonight I know that I am I
actually am excited for it this time to
be honest this time anyway I am and for
one thing I'm looking forward to the
spectacle of a democratic debate
featuring not one but two billionaires
two billionaires I'm not sure if steyr
made the cut this time around I hope
that he did because either way there are
two billionaires in the field vying for
the Democratic nomination so you got two
billionaire's a bunch of millionaires a
bunch of white people bait and that's it
right basically the Democratic field
looks exactly like the kind of party
that the Democrats accused the
Republicans of being and that's great
I do expect tonight for just a very
brief preview that the phrase buying the
election the accusation of buying the
election will be uttered quite a bit all
of the mere millionaires on stage will
valiantly stand up against the
billionaire or billionaires and accuse
them of buying the election but keep in
mind as the millionaires complain about
the billionaire buying the election that
they aren't upset about elections being
bought per se they have no problem with
that it's just they're upset about
they're upset about somebody buying an
election with their own money that's
that's the issue for Sanders and Warren
of course their preferred method is to
buy the election by bribing voters with
other people's money so they want to use
your money to brought to bribe the
voters and that's their issue Bloomberg
at least has the the decency to bribe
folks with his own money and that's the
that's the thing that I think offends
the Warrens and the Sanders of the world
so remember that tonight you know nobody
has ever attempted to buy an election as
brazenly as especially Bernie Sanders is
attempting to buy it by promising free
everything basically it's just that
again he's using your money to do it the
idea that somebody would use their own
money to do anything is very offensive
to Bernie Sanders so I'm sure we'll
we'll hear a lot about that tonight okay
enough about the debate for now I want
to talk about narcissism a
a not unrelated topic to be sure and
that's gonna be the theme of the show
today
or at least of the first couple of
things that we talked about
I believe that narcissism is the Great
Plague of modern society and since our
society is so into narcissists
and has so constructed itself around
narcissism it has also come up with many
names and and labels and ways of
discussing narcissism to make it seem
Noble or brave or bold right now I think
it may help to begin with a definition I
don't always trust websites like
Psychology Today but in this case I
think Psychology Today provides a pretty
good description of what narcissism ears
is here's what the site says narcissism
is characterized by it says a hunger for
appreciation or admiration a sense of
specialness and a desire to be the
center of attention and an expectation
of special treatment reflecting
perceived higher status okay so that's
narcissism now here's a great example of
it in my view there's this video that's
gone viral online it's a video of
somebody a woman I think I could be
wrong performing a bit of poetry about
her struggles with trying to get her
hair cut as a quote non-binary person
and this is being hailed as like I said
noble brave bold beautiful but really I
could just not imagine a better
illustration of narcissism in fact it
would not be an exaggeration to say that
this that this poem that I'll play for
you right now is is perhaps the most
powerful poem about narcissism that I've
ever heard so without further ado here
it is watch this I need a haircut so
option one as the salon that's women Li
world of perfumed femininity with which
I feel like I have little affinity or
option 2 as the barbers which isn't much
better since this voice and these whales
in my chest make me feel like an
infiltrator
but barbers or salon when I get to the
chair before we can even touch on my
hair there's this question which hangs
there on uttered an awkward they made
all the more awkward when they see I
know this is awkward and through the
matter they ask if I'm a boy or a girl
my trans and my gay and I don't know
what to see sometimes I packed my labels
to make other people feel ok but it's
never enough to see where I'd like to be
trimmed or shaved they need to know my
sex how else can they charge the
appropriate rate I'm sure you've seen
the signs change trim 5 quad women's
trim name it doesn't matter how I define
anyway when the hair on her head charged
by what's between our legs and as usual
there always seems to be a higher price
to pay for those who are female you see
what what you saw there that's not a
poem about being non-binary mostly
because there's no such thing as being
non-binary that doesn't exist that's a
poem about as I said being a narcissist
and we'll talk more about that in a
moment but first a word from Vince aro
watches with this new year you know it's
time to get started on improving
yourself and no one knows that better
than one of my favorite sponsors to tell
you about them all the time VIN chair oh
these guys Jay they just know how
important is to look and feel your best
and they're here to help you keep stay
motivated through 2020 and beyond if you
look in to upgrade your look you don't
have to waste money on a cheap cookie
cutter watch that doesn't get you
noticed and getting a watch there's a
great way to kind of upgrade it class
things up a little bit and if you do it
with VIN chair oh then you know that
your these are going to be affordable
options but not cheap and there is a
difference between those those two
things finding a watch that's stylish
bold and built to last can cost a cost
of pretty penny
that's why I've inch arrows want Venera
watches is changing that they believe
that you deserve to look good no matter
your budget you deserve better than
settling for something that's
underwhelming or that looks cheap so
head over to ven terra watches calm
slash walsh you can check out my
favorite pics take advantage of my
special discount while you shop and
remember to use code walls Finch arrow
understands the frustrations of online
shopping these guys
they really get it and that's why they
make it as easy as possible for you the
chair offers a free shipping 30-day
returns which means you know you could
try it on if you don't like it you can
send it back but I think you will like
it but there's always that option it's
stress free shopping with fair and
honest prices and it just gives you it
gives you what you need and and this is
why if you don't believe me you don't
have to believe you don't trust me go
check out vin sharrows five star reviews
on their say they've got over 20,000 of
them so just trust the people that have
bought these watches and can tell you
about it this is something that you'll
use and this is this is a this is a
timepiece that will last as they should
so this deal is really too good to pass
up you get the year started the right
way go to VI n CRO watches dot-com
forward slash Walsh and use my discount
code Walsh for a discount at checkout do
not pay full price on these beautiful
timepieces you don't need to use my code
Walsh at checkout again that's of inch
arrow watches dot-com all right um
so you saw the video the poem and this
is the kind of thing that these days
were supposed to approach with hushed
reverence and say Shh everyone listen
she's talking about her lived experience
this is this is profound and meaningful
when really almost everybody is rolling
their eyes at least internally maybe not
externally because I think they're not
allowed to they think it says that's not
the right that's that that's a that's a
terrible and bigoted reaction it's not
it's the right reaction let's talk about
why first of all this person says that
her identity as complex and fascinating
and poetic as it is just can't be
described by or contained by the labels
male or female this is that's not enough
she needs something other than that well
no she doesn't because nobody is other
than that you're either male or female
okay her case female I think now you can
be a female who prefers short hair and
baggy clothes that's fine
that is actually nothing to do
with your status as male or female if
you're a female with different fashion
sense and aesthetic sensibilities from
most feet other females then you're just
a female with different fashion senses
and aesthetic sensibilities for most of
the females that's it it's not
complicated we don't need a whole new
category to describe you
you're still a female just a female and
that's fine it really is or you're a
male and that's fine too everybody is
one or the other it is indeed a binary
system that's what a binary system is
where everywhere everyone or everything
in the system is one thing or another
and that's how it is for members of the
human species it is it definitely a
binary system there is no third sex it
doesn't exist now there are people of
either sex a small minority who suffer
from deformities or abnormalities but
those are deformities and abnormalities
within the binary and the whole way we
know that they are deformities or
abnormalities is because they are within
the binary but some people have
convinced themselves that these
so-called traditional labels these
standard categories are just too small
you know too too shallow too boring too
routine to contain them to contain them
in their enormity they're just so
interesting and so deep and so amazing
and incredible and different and
manifold and nuanced you heard it in the
clip you know the rest of the world
almost everyone else can satisfy
themselves with these labels but not me
no I'm I'm I'm I'm just different I'm
something else entirely I'm not like
them I'm not like you not like anyone I
have what was you know what was that on
psychology today I have a sense of
specialness and a desire to be the
center of attention that's what it is
and then she makes this whole long thing
out of choosing who is going to cut her
hair you know even claiming that the
barber or stylist will ask her if she's
gay or trans which first of all I
guarantee that doesn't happen okay
you're not gonna sit down at the
barbershop with it so you're gay does
that get Gapers yeah
I've never been asked that personally I
really doubt that she's ever been asked
that at the bar because it's totally
irrelevant it's also irrelevant what sex
you are they're not gonna ask you that
either
you know what makes female hair more
expensive is not that it's female but
that generally there's more of it and
women want more done to it and so if
you're gonna cut female hair it takes
longer it requires more skill and talent
and training and so it's more expensive
but if you're okay with just getting a
three on the sides a little off the top
like the kind of thing that men at that
that men ask for when they sit down at
the barber then you're going to get the
same prices it's that simple
you see nobody really gives a damn
that's the thing this some person is
imagining a scenario where the whole
world is hanging on the edge of its seat
wanting to know what she'll do what kind
of haircut is she gonna get but nobody
gives a damn that's the thing just get
over yourself get that that's the answer
most of the time when you see this stuff
Rob non-binary oh no no just get over
yourself get over yourself and you know
get the kind of cut you want and shut up
about it
that's that's it nobody cares this is a
realization that we could all benefit
from something that we all need to keep
in mind I think even those of us who are
not necessarily inclined to write slam
poetry about our experiences at the
barbershop we could still bear this in
mind too and that is that when it comes
down to it almost nobody actually cares
what we're doing 99% of the time
99% of the time the feeling that we have
of being judged or watched or whatever
is an illusion nobody is judging because
nobody cares and even the ones who are
judging which does happen sometimes they
don't really care that much they're
gonna forget about it ten seconds later
they're not gonna go about their day
thinking about you so when you walk into
a room and you think oh no what are
people gonna think about me and what I'm
doing and what I feel and what I say
what are people gonna think
the answer is almost nothing they're
gonna think almost nothing about it
because they're just as absorbed in
their own ego as you are in yours I'm
not sure if that's much of a comfort it
certainly isn't doesn't tell us anything
great about the nature of humanity but
that's the way it is it's the truth okay
all right more to talk about but first
you know it's hard to imagine but there
was a time a long time ago when if
somebody was knocking on your door you
had to like physically be there and if
you weren't there then they would just
go away and you would never know who was
there that's a bad way back in the dark
ages but as someone who's had ring for a
long time now I can't imagine going back
to that because ring it gives you peace
of mind the convenience that comes with
it and it you know it just makes not
only your home but a makes neighborhood
safer now you probably know with ring
about they're smart video doorbells it's
what most people know them for the
cameras that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you to stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you'll get an
alert and you'll be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone from
anywhere in the world doesn't matter
where you are you don't have to be there
that's the point and this you know what
I always go back to is the is the
convenience factor of it which of course
is a big thing but also the peace of
mind and security of knowing that you've
got an eye on things and you know who's
at your house because you have a right
to know that information as a subscriber
you have a special offer on a ring
welcome kit available right now at ring
comm slash Walsh the kit includes a
video doorbell and chime Pro which is
just what you need to start a to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go-to ring comm slash Walsh
that's ring comm / Walsh by the way this
was pretty good Elizabeth Warren she was
I think talking to a culinary Union
yesterday trying her best to pander and
you know sometimes it goes off the rails
when Elizabeth Warren tries to pander
because he's trying to approximate what
no
people say in and it's it doesn't always
work out because if she's got a little
bit of a robotic Hillary Clinton thing
going on with her and so this is this is
what she came up with watch yes when you
need something cleaned call a woman that
was that's actually what she said and as
a husband you know it's not very often I
agree with Elizabeth Warren or I have
the the inclination to shout Amen but as
a husband I I do I have to say amen to
that yes ma'am I I totally agree and
that is generally my strategy as well my
wife is not a big fan of that being my
strategy but hey I now I have the
endorsement of Elizabeth Elizabeth
Warren said you want it done you got to
call a woman that's the that's the
enlighten thing to do I just never
realized I guess that Elizabeth Warren
is a trad wife and so that's that's the
that's the headline here personally I
really hope she gives a speech sometime
at like a subway restaurant if you need
a sandwich made call a woman good stuff
from Elizabeth Warren okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna
moving on here I wanted to defend Jake
Paul for a minute defend him against
narcissus because that's the theme today
of course Jake Paul famous youtuber the
kids tell me got himself in trouble on
Monday because he tweeted about anxiety
and what we know about things like
anxiety and depression is that if you're
gonna wade into these waters and say
anything at all about these subjects it
better be something that adheres very
strictly to Modern Orthodox thinking on
these subjects because if not you're
gonna have a whole bunch of narcissist
jumping down your throat telling you
that you aren't qualified to talk about
these things implying that they are
somehow I'm never explaining why they
are but you know you're not qualified
they are and they're gonna let you know
it well Jake bought and realized this so
he said in a tweet which I believe has
since been deleted he said remember
anxiety is created by you sometimes you
got a left let life play out and remind
yourself to be happy and that the answer
we'll come chill your mind out go for a
walk talk to a friend that was the tweet
it's been deleted I don't know if he's
apologized yet probably will if he
hasn't yet I imagine and it provoked
thousands of snide condescending angry
reactions from people basically going
you don't know anything about anxiety
the way that I've experienced it I'm an
anxiety expert your thoughts are so
shallow you fool follow you were as deep
and interesting and tortured a soul as
me then you'd realize all of your
thoughts about anxiety are wrong because
they're not like mine Newsweek has
compiled some tweets reacting to the
Jake Paul tweet which because this is
how news is reported these days I'm not
going to read any of them it doesn't
really matter the point is that you know
people are angry that he said this about
anxiety but first of all I think it's
it's relevant to point out that he's
exactly right and the point that he's
making is unavoidably demonstrably true
no matter what explanation you prefer
for anxiety because no matter what it is
something generated by the brain right
by the mind
doesn't mean it's your fault but it is
generated by the self I mean what other
option would there be if anxiety is not
created by you then who is it created by
the only other option I could think of
is some kind of some kind of spiritual
warfare thing where you're blaming it on
the devil now I believe in spiritual
warfare and even I don't think that the
the the brain makes anxiety and your
brain is your brain it's not your
neighbor Jim's brain it's your brains in
your head and so it is technically true
to say that anxiety is created by you
that's not the same thing as blaming you
it's not it's not an insult either and
yet it also doesn't tell the whole story
but that's why the best reaction to a
statement like this is either to ignore
it if you want or to add to it to
respond to have a conversation isn't
that what everyone always says we should
be doing have a conversation about
mental
health in America and so we were always
told to have this conversation but we
can't because all anyone is ever looking
to do is compete over who has suffered
the most psychologically and who
therefore is most suited to issue
decrees on the subject I mean the last
thing we can do is have a conversation
about it and in anyone who's got any
kind of platform and has made the
mistake of just sort of sharing some
thoughts on something like depression or
anxiety has learned this no no we can't
have a conversation about this you
kidding is the last thing we could talk
about because people take it very
personally if you don't say exactly what
they think you should say people are
people are very protective of their
anxiety in their depression and if you
dare say anything that is not 100% what
they want you to say they are going to
lose their minds over that's the way it
goes but there is nonetheless a lot of
truth to what Jake Paul said of course
of course anxiety is self generated in
whatever way in some way you know that's
of course the case and of course taking
a walk and relaxing can help of course I
can can help anybody no matter how
severe your anxiety is and I say that as
somebody who has a lot of anxiety does
that give me special permission or
special credentials to talk about this
is this a competition am I saying
I've more anxiety than you so you have
to listen to me no it's not it's not
special all humans have anxiety and a
lot of it it is an essential aspect of
the human condition it is inseparable
from our existence as people anxiety
comes I think at bottom from the fact
that we are mortal beings we are aware
of our mortality we are aware of of time
we are aware of the past in the future
and that we are situated always somewhat
precariously at the Nexus of those two
points anxiety comes from wanting and
not having from having and fearing that
you'll lose what you have from fears of
things you know about and things you
don't know about from disappointment and
regret and guilt and it's
etc etc anxiety comes from a lot of
things and it mixes together into an
unholy stew in your mind that's what
anxiety is now before you claim oh no
that's just regular anxiety you don't
know what it's like to have irregular
anxiety clinical anxiety like me you
don't know what that's like well how how
could you possibly know that your
anxiety is more serious or worse or
whatever than anybody else's all these
assumptions people make how and how
could you possibly know that Jake Paul's
experience of anxiety is less
instructive less severe less valuable or
whatever than yours you know I'll tell
you you can't you just can't I mean you
have no idea what you're talking about
because you can't be inside someone
else's mind you have absolutely no idea
what's going on inside there all you can
assume is that when it comes to
something like anxiety everyone
basically knows where you're coming from
because you're a person and so are they
to assume anything else is by definition
narcissism but there are a lot of
narcissists who take a weird kind of
pride in their real or imagined mental
conditions believing that it makes them
special and more interesting and deeper
and more troubled than everybody else
and I you know I'm really tired of it I
honestly am everyone has the right to
talk about anxiety everyone has
experience with it your assumption that
your experience is different is just
that in assumption and a bad one a
narcissistic one depression is the same
thing you know that that's that's
another thing that comes with being
human which isn't to diminish it lots of
things come with being human that are
still nonetheless significant so this is
not reductive but we have to get to a
point where we could just talk about
these things and people can share their
thoughts and be honest and go out on a
limb by simply giving their perspective
without everyone else getting ready to
you know fall down on their fainting
couches about it if the person's
respective on the human condition
doesn't exactly align with their own one
of the dumbest and most dangerous things
we've done I think as a culture is to
medicalize the human condition and then
to decree that certain people are the
experts the scientific experts on the
subject the subject of being human so
much so that everyone else has to defer
to them even though we're all human and
there's no reason really to think that
these so-called experts are somehow more
expertly human than anybody else
so when Paul said this about with Jake
Paul said this about anxiety and I've
gotten this many times myself when I've
talked about these sorts of issues a lot
of the responses were you're not a
psychiatrist where's your psychiatric
degree well first of all everyone's
saying that none of them are
psychiatrists either
so yet they feel perfectly suited to
pontificate all they want because they
believe that their experience is so much
more relevant than everyone else's
because they're narcissists but in any
case who says that psychiatrists have
some especially true or valuable insight
into something as basic and human as
anxiety now I'm not saying they have no
insight into it but but but who's to say
that they're experts who appointed them
experts I mean you would reserve
psychiatrists have solved anxiety after
thousands of years of human of you know
human civilization of people writing and
thinking and talking about anxiety
psychiatrists came along in 50 years
they solved yep they're experts they got
it listen to them you know III would
have an easier time deferring to certain
philosophers on the issue of anxiety
that I would psychiatrists at least they
understand the philosophers do what kind
of issue they're dealing with at least
they aren't materialists and minimalist
trying to reduce every damn thing to a
matter of neurological chemistry you
know Kierkegaard I would
consider maybe something of an expert on
anxiety but that's only because I've
read what he said about it and it seems
to me that he really did have a great
insight into it I mean you know this is
not a an appeal to Authority it's just
it's more I've read what he says and to
me it seems like it makes sense here it
by the way here's a here's here's
Kierkegaard on anxiety Kierkegaard says
anxiety may be compared with dizziness
he whose eyes happen to look down the
yawning abyss becomes dizzy but what is
the reason for this it's just as much in
his own eye as in the abyss for suppose
he had not looked down hence anxiety is
the dizziness of freedom which emerges
when the spirit wants to posit the
synthesis and freedom looks down into
its own possibility laying hold of its
finiteness to support itself freedom
succumbs to dizziness now I understand
about 60% of that okay check regards a
little bit difficult to understand but
what I take from that is anxiety is the
dizziness of freedom that it's sort of
this tension between us being finite
beings and yet having seemingly infinite
freedom now there's an idea maybe it's
true maybe it isn't but to me this seems
much closer to the truth than any
reductive medicalised rhetoric you get
from psychiatrists but then again you
know I'm only judging Kierkegaard's
thoughts on anxiety based on my own
experience with it which is the only
thing that anyone can do psychiatrists
included I just wish that psychiatrists
would admit that much of what they do is
actually philosophy they are making
judgments about the human condition more
than that they are judging not only how
a person is and what a person is but how
a person ought to be and that is a
philosophical judgment all the way
through one we're free to take or leave
but the problem is that we just we just
trusted implicitly
and we don't recognize it as a
philosophical judgment so we've got the
psychiatric community making all of
these declarations about well this is
the right amount of a certain
personality trait people are supposed to
have and this is the right amount of
something like depression or anxiety and
if it if it goes beyond this totally
arbitrary line that we've drawn and that
we couldn't possibly explain why we drew
it there but we did if it goes beyond
that that's a problem now it's a medical
condition or something like attention
you know there's a certain amount of
attention that a child is supposed to be
able to pay you know in school and if so
here's the line of attention that we've
just drawn in in the ether and in
magically in there and if they're below
that line then they have a deficit of
attention and that's abnormal and now
it's a disease says who where are you
getting this from according to WHO
exactly
I mean you've decided that when it comes
to ADHD that kids are supposed to be
this certain way and are supposed to
have this amount of attention who says
they're supposed to be that
when you find a kid that that is not as
able to pay attention who's to say he's
not supposed to be that way I'm not
saying he is supposed to be that way I'm
just saying how did you decide he's not
or you find some people that are more
inclined to anxiety than others and we
say well no they're not supposed to be
that way says who I mean maybe you're
right maybe not but supposed to me what
are we comparing it to we've come up
with this idea of the sort of normal
neurological person that we're all
comparing ourselves to but who is that
person you see who were we comparing
ourselves to I have too much anxiety
well maybe you do but too much as
opposed to what where's the where's the
line where's the level where is the
perfect brain that we're matching our
brains up against and saying oh no our
chemistry doesn't quite mix with that
and so you know we need to we need to
fiddle with these chemicals and these
chemicals to make it the perfect brain
it's just basic questions that nobody
seems to ask we just say we just we just
we have we have handed the human
condition over to the psychiatric
industry and said you know yep that's
their thing
they own it we'll just listen to
whatever they say maybe not maybe we
shouldn't do that maybe there's more to
it than that all right you know I want
to give a shout out to all of our daily
wire members you know you guys are the
ones that keep us in business we love
making content that matters and while
we're on the frontlines of the culture
war we can't do it without your support
that's the main thing if you're still
skeptical about joining the daily wire a
readers pass is a great start and a
great value a readers pass will enable
news junkies to read our articles
ad-free which is a great benefit
including op-eds from ben shapiro which
are exclusive for daily wire Members
Only you get that upgraded experience
and in-depth analysis from our
editor-in-chief you also get access to
our mobile app which has really become
popular with all of our members you can
read all of our stories on mobile you
can receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content it's
perfect for when you want to stay up to
date on the go this Membership tier is
already a bargain at just three bucks a
month I mean three bucks a month is it
well right now we're offering one month
for 99 cents that's mobile
ad-free access to all of the daily wired
news exclusive op-eds from ben shapiro
breaking news and updates on our mobile
app all for the low price of $1 less
than a dollar so it's definitely worth
it give it a shot yeah nothing to lose
okay finally um
researchers in Belgium did a study and
they are now claiming that insect butter
tastes like real butter and nobody can
tell the difference they fed and this is
real I promise they fed people cake made
from the fat of black soldier fly larvae
and they said that nobody could tell
that it was from little baby flies and
so it's all good let's just get our
butter from flies now why not now let me
say this first of all I've put my money
where my mouth is on this very show and
I have eaten insects on the show and I
can tell you that don't buy into the
hype of all the stuff you're hearing but
I know insects taste it
insects tastes exactly as you would
expect insects to taste if you were
blindfolded and someone gave you an
insect and you would know that it's an
insect not just based on the texture
either but just whatever you think if
you think well what do insects taste
like it just imagine it it tastes like
that exactly what you're thinking that's
what it tastes like
um second general point here we really
need to stop calling non dairy things
butter and milk and cream okay if it's
not made with actual dairy then it's not
butter it's not milk it's not cream so
forget about insects for a minute there
is no such thing as almond milk there's
no such thing as coconut milk those are
all lies that is false advertising just
because it's white and it comes in a
carton doesn't make it milk nor does it
taste like milk and in my whole life you
know every time and I usually fall for
it that's why I get at a certain point I
start taking it personally because every
time someone says I don't know you hey
you got to try this you know you have to
try X it tastes just like Y whatever it
is every time I try it and it doesn't
taste
at all like why it's in it that that's
the case for all the non-dairy fake milk
doesn't taste like milk turkey bacon
doesn't taste like real bacon veggie
burgers don't taste at all like real
burgers insect cake doesn't taste like
real cake I assume all of these
imposters offend me on a moral level as
well as a as a culinary one so my
message is have the courage to be what
you are and to embrace it okay if you're
a jug of coconut drippings which is what
coconut milk really is then then that's
what you should call yourself if you're
a pack of flavorless
turkey strips call yourself that not
bacon if your insect goop then call
yourself insect goop not butter let's
all have the courage to be who we are
this is literally the speech that I give
every time I go to the grocery store I
stand in the milk aisle and I give this
pep talk to the coconut milk it's at the
point now where they just call the
police every time I walk in the door
it's it's a whole thing anyway that's my
inspirational message for the day hope
you guys have a great day
enjoy the debate tonight we'll talk
about it tomorrow Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]